Ось так "клином" військові іноді переганяють F-15 та F-16 на далекі відстані.
Але поки що не в Україну.
Хоча дискусія про поставки західних літаків вже активно ведеться.
Польща готова передати Україні винищувачі F-16 у координації з НАТО.
Про це заявив польський прем'єр Матеуш Моравецький.
За словами його колеги прем’єра Нідерландів Марка Рютте, жодних табу немає, але є критерії, які не можна порушувати.
Їх сформулював французький президент Еммануель Макрон.
Це залежить від запитів, які надходять, а не від чуток навколо.
Ці запити ще не сформульовані, але щоразу, коли ми отримуємо їх, ми дивимося, що, на нашу думку,
може бути корисним, що ми можемо зробити і в межах якого часу.
Другий критерій - переконатися, що це не призведе до ескалації, щоб спорядження, яке ми відправляємо,
не було використано для удару по російській території.
Третій критерій полягає в тому, що ці поставки не повинні послабити здатність французької армії
захистити власну територію та наших громадян.
Президент США Джо Байден сказав коротке "ні" на запитання журналістів,
чи планують Сполучені Штати передати Україні винищувачі четвертого покоління.
При цьому ще минулого літа Конгрес схвалив фінансування програми підготовки українських пілотів
на американських винищувачах, виділивши на це сто мільйонів доларів.
Це так само, як і з танками: під час модернізації військово-повітряних сил у Європі та США з'являється обладнання,
яке вони потенційно можуть передати Україні. Це був би ще один крок до ескалації.
Але я думаю, що зараз Захід хоче подивитися, як Україна впорається з танками, а потім оцінити ситуацію.
Тож це питання, безумовно, буде включено до порядку денного майбутніх зустрічей у Рамштайні,
і ми побачимо, що тиск наростатиме. Але я не очікував би, що з цього питання будуть ухвалені якісь рішення вже найближчим часом.
Видання Politico з посиланням на європейських військових та дипломатів пише,
що обговорення перспектив постачання винищувачів Україні вже розпочалося.
Очікується, що це питання спричинить ще більше суперечок, ніж постачання Києву танків.
За оцінками Повітряних сил України, для захисту неба потрібно до 200 багатоцільових літаків.
Запит на винищувачі існує вже кілька місяців, і його активно розглядають як у Вашингтоні,
так і в столицях союзників. Багато хто вважає, що підійшли б американські F-16.
Але, чесно кажучи, якщо розглянути можливості, як задовольнити цей запит Зеленського,
мені здається, краще було б поставити Україні радянські літаки з Польщі,
від інших союзників, в арсеналах яких є багато обладнання радянських часів.
Ці літаки добрі. Це літаки, на яких українські пілоти літали раніше і для яких в Україні є логістика.
Думаю, що слід розглянути такі варіанти в першу чергу.
І, можливо, для того, щоб ці літаки були відправлені в Україну,
США могли б надати свої F-16 країні, яка віддасть свої винищувачі радянської розробки.
Багато західних країн не готові постачати Києву наступальне озброєння, не кажучи вже про винищувачі.
Як раніше щодо танків, так тепер і щодо літаків - канцлер ФРН Олаф Шольц висловлюється проти.
Він окреслив червону лінію: постачати Україні бойові літаки Німеччина не готова.
Я дуже рано дав зрозуміти, що про винищувачі не йдеться, і ясно дав зрозуміти це, коли ми обговорювали безпольотну зону над Україною.
Я також сказав американському президенту, що ми не будемо цього робити, і ця позиція не змінилася і не зміниться.
Експерти зазначають, що в питанні винищувачів - на відміну від танків - роль Німеччини буде обмеженою.
Адже літаки - не сильна сторона арсеналу ФРН.
Канцлер ФРН не матиме тих важелів впливу і тієї ролі, яку він грав при ухваленні рішення про постачання танків німецького виробництва.
Тож насправді країна, яка має ухвалити рішення про постачання F-16   - це Сполучені Штати.
Тому я думаю, що у цьому питанні канцлер залишиться лише спостерігачем.
Після довгих місяців вагань Німеччина та США таки дали свою згоду на відправку "Леопардів" та "Абрамсів" в Україну,
і Київ не втрачає надії, що з часом вдасться отримати й літаки та далекобійні ракети.
Президент України Володимир Зеленський вже обговорив цю тему з генсеком НАТО Єнсом Столтенбергом.
Він назвав це "мрією" і "важливим завданням".
Маємо відкрити постачання також далекобійних ракет для України.
Важливо: ми маємо розширювати й нашу співпрацю в артилерії,
ми маємо вийти на постачання літаків для України. І це мрія.
І це задача.
Серед західних літаків найбільше Київ хотів би отримати F-16.
Це легкий американський багатофункціональний винищувач четвертого покоління.
Загалом випущено понад чотири з половиною тисячі таких літаків.
Це наймасовіший винищувач четвертого покоління, який числиться на озброєнні 24 держав світу.
Коштує залежно від модифікації в середньому 34 мільйони доларів.
F-16 здатен виконувати практично всі військові завдання:
від повітряних боїв до високоточного бомбардування і підтримки наземних сил.
Його цінують за зручність у пілотуванні та обслуговуванні.
Україна має намір з тією ж наполегливістю добиватися цих літаків, як раніше танків.